[Musique]
bienvenue en mai c'est ce qui te plaît
et ce qui nous plaît c'est paris saclay
un spring dans cette émission nous
sommes allés à la rencontre de tous ceux
et toutes celles qui ont participé à cet
événement un événement qui s'est tenu en
grande partie ici à l'école normale
supérieure paris saclay c'étaient les 20
et 21 mai c'est le ministre de
l'économie bruno le maire qui a ouvert
cette édition parmi les temps forts à
plateaux télévisés le circuit et les
villages de l'innovation ou encore
springs 50 alors les grands groupes
comme danone total servier les
chercheurs les investisseurs les stars
peur tous les acteurs du territoire ont
répondu présent ils se sont retrouvés
pour deux jours pour parler donc de cet
écosystème unique en europe celui de
paris saclay vous à les entendre ils
nous expliquent pourquoi paris saclay ce
prix est important pourquoi c'est devenu
un rendez vous incontournable et bien
sûr notre agenda
ce sera la fin de cette émission
[Musique]
participez à paris saclay spring est
devenu une évidence même pour les grands
groupes
une table ronde exceptionnelle success
mais klaus a réuni les dirigeants de
total danone ou encore servier et parmi
les fidèles il ya aussi eds carmen munoz
dormoy et la directrice déléguée r&d
d'edf leur centre de recherche est
installé sur le plateau elle nous
explique comment paris saclay spring
permet de développer des partenariats y
avait aussi de dénicher les startups
innovantes avec une priorité pour le
groupe
la décarbonation de l'économie
[Musique]
pour rêver c'est une évidence d'être
présents ici aujourd'hui à paris saclay
spring parce que nous sommes un acteur
très important sur les plateaux notre
recherche et développement est implanté
sur place nous avons mille chercheurs
qui travaillent à côté et nous sommes
extrêmement connecter avec les acteurs
du plateau que ce soit d'autres acteurs
industriels avec lesquels on a des
partenariats que ce soit les
établissements d'enseignement chez qui
nous ré croûtons beaucoup que ce soit
des thésards ou des stagiaires et mais
aussi avec des start up avec lesquels
nous collaborons des façons très assidu
au niveau des notes pressent sur les
plateaux
nous attendons encore de renforcer les
liens avec tous les acteurs présents
donc que ce soit les écoles avec les
développements des laboratoires communs
de recherche pointue ensemble où que ce
soit avec tout l'écosystème des start up
qui sont pressantes
clairement si on est sur les plateaux et
paris saclay c'est pour profiter d'une
recherche d'excellence et de la
mutualisation que nous pouvons avoir
avec entreprises et puis établissements
d'enseignement et de recherche un
aujourd'hui et notre intervention
c'était au tour des la décarbonation des
l'économie et c'est quelque chose qui
est très important et pour nous on a
fait même la raison d'être du groupe f
et notre recherche et développement
travaille pour atteindre la neutralité
carbone en 2050 avec toutes les
évolutions technologiques et sur nos
deux piliers qui sont les énergies
renouvelables et puis la production
nucléaire
nous avons énormément des laboratoires
à proximité des paris saclay et c'était
un sujet important pour nous a portés à
connaissance de nos partenaires les
start-up justement 50 d'entre elles ont
pu se faire connaître c'est l'objectif
de spring 50 d'halkali à néolithique en
passant par cheikh myspace autant de
start up en devenir autant de projets
développés dans des domaines très variés
l'espace le développement durable ou
encore la santé
coup de projecteur sur cinq start up
elles font partie de cette promotion
2021 leurs jeunes fondateurs nous
dévoilent leurs projets et vous verrez
pour eux strict 50 est vraiment une
opportunité à ne pas rater
bonjour je suis romain lui tienne
directeur général et co-fondateur de
chars myspace cher myspace est une
société française du new space basé à
paris et spécialisé dans la sécurité et
la durabilité des opérations spatiales
avec mon associé damien le président de
la société nous avons monté une équipe
d'une dizaine de personnes avec des
profils variés pour constituer un
catalogue d'objets parmi les plus
complets au monde
aujourd'hui nous opérons deux télescopes
en normandie et en provence pour
réaliser des observations de divers
objets spatiaux et nous avons mise en
production un service d'évitement des
collisions en orbite pour les satellites
je suis très attaché au territoire du
plateau de saclay de parme et les études
à l'école polytechnique et de par ma
thèse et mes travaux de recherche menés
au laboratoire de physique des plasmas
sprint va être l'événement idéal pour
reconnecter avec l'écosystème de saclay
après cette période de qu'ovide et de
créer de nouveaux liens
[Musique]
bonjour je m'appelle laurent le gars je
suis co fondateur de la société halkali
une start up issue d'un projet de
collaboration entre le sénat et renault
qui visait à repenser les architectures
électriques électroniques des véhicules
de demain aujourd'hui un véhicule est
constitué d'environ 100 calculateur
chacun répartis dans la voiture et qui
s'occupe de chaque fonctionnalité
électronique de la voiture
dans le futur on vise à centraliser
l'ensemble de ces technologies autour du
logiciel et développer des véhicules
autour du logiciel
alkali permet dans ce contexte de
fournir des solutions logicielles
permettant d'intégrer l'ensemble de ces
briques hétérogènes l'issue de plusieurs
fournisseurs sur un calculateur
centralisée de manière sûre et rapide
nous sommes déçus de technologie
développée entièrement sur le plateau de
paris saclay à l'origine du projet entre
renault à guyancourt et le cea list à
palaiseau est aujourd'hui alkali est
implantée à orsay chez incuballiance et
nous bénéficions ainsi de l'ensemble des
possibilités ouvertes sur plateau de
paris saclay nous sommes très heureux de
participer à paris saclay spring pour
nous l'intérêt principal est de s'ouvrir
au monde de l'établissement paris-saclay
d'avoir des échanges avec à la fois les
académiques la partie scolaire et
surtout les grandes entreprises
implantées sur plateau de paris-saclay
de bénéficier des échanges
technologiques et aussi des chances sur
le savoir-faire seules les bonnes
manières de travailler de collaborer
ensemble pour proposer des produits à
plus forte valeur ajoutée
[Musique]
c'est d'in'tech développent des procédés
de bio stimulation de la germination des
semences agricoles à destination des
producteurs de semences et des maisons
sont en série
c'est une jeune compagnie on est en
phase de création est normalement la
création devra intervenir d'ici juin on
espère qu'il va bien en train de faire
une première levée de fonds qui va nous
permettre de démarrer notre activité
continuer notre développement technique
et aussi démarrer une activité
commerciale avec des premières
prestations de services si d'in'tech en
fait aimer dans les laboratoires de
l'inps rails de versailles donc on est
des purs produits du territoire de
paris-saclay l'histoire à la commencer
en 2016
on a commencé avec un premier projet
idée que c'est pas bon ça crée et
ensuite on a fait un projet de
maturation avec la sat paris saclay en
et l'aventuré se poursuit sur le
territoire de paris saclay convient
c'est une installation sur le territoire
versaillais dans les procès deux
prochaines semaines qui arrivent le fait
d'être sélectionné pour le spring fifty
de paris-saclay c'est une belle
reconnaissance pour le projet et aussi
pour une belle reconnaissance pour tous
les acteurs qui nous accompagnent je
pense notamment à la sat paris-saclay
mais aussi à l'institut jean pierre
mongin dont est issue la technologie
qu'on va exploiter
[Musique]
je suis leur pichard aux signaux de la
start-up seaview je suis optométristes
donc spécialiste de la vision j'ai créé
sea view en 2016 avec nos confondateur
également auto maîtrise et spécialiste
de la vision et notre objectif ça a été
de développer une solution qui permette
de rendre accessible l'examen de vue à
tous l'objectif de sibiu ça a été de
modéliser le travers d'une intelligence
artificielle
cet examen de vue cet acte complexes
pour permettre à une personne même
inexpérimentés en utilisant notre
solution de façon très simple intuitive
pas à pas d'obtenir la meilleure
prescription lunettes dans le temps de
plus courts c'est-à-dire à peu près sept
minutes
cette solution est destinée aux
professionnels de santé que ce soit les
opticiens optométristes sur le marché
français et international ainsi que les
ophtalmologistes qui ont besoin de
délégués de plus en plus cette tâche
afin de gagner du temps et de permettre
d'optimiser leur parcours patient
nous sommes très fiers et très honorés
d'être sélectionné pour le paris saclay
ce prix c'est une très belle vitrine
et puis ça en plus pour nous une très
belle occasion ça tombe pile poil avec
notre agenda on est en pleine levée de
fonds et ça va être l'occasion de
rencontrer des investisseurs dans le
cadre de cet événement
[Musique]
bonjour je m'appelle nicolas cruaud je
suis président de la start up née all it
chez néolithique fait des granulats donc
c'est des granulats qui ont les
propriétés mécaniques et
environnementales de granulats naturels
sauf que eux ils ont un impact
environnemental très fort ils vont
réduire de 5% l'impact carbone mondiale
leur secret c'est que c'est pas des
granulats issus de carrière mais c'est
des granulats qui ont été transformés à
partir de déchets ménagers non
recyclables donc la poubelle noir de 2,2
chacun de chez vous aujourd'hui j'ai
pitcher au concours de pitch du sprint
50 donc qui regroupe les 50 startups les
plus prometteuses de paris saclay c'est
un pitch qui est qu'à une assez grande
importance pour moi parce que c'est un
pitch qui et qui est diffusé à de
nombreux acteurs de l'écosystème paris
saclay en particulier également à des
investisseurs j'ai déjà deux reçu un
mail d'un investisseur donc a priori ça
va plutôt bien marché et l'intérêt du
spring c'est de créer un écosystème
entre les différentes start-up récentes
ou plus vieilles et pour lier à c'est en
fait de rentrer dans les clous vraiment
dans l'écosystème de paris siècle avec
les industriels les investisseurs et
tout ce cadre que paris saclay offre
pour l'innovation
oh
[Musique]
tu fais à repérer c'est bien mais
trouver des investisseurs c'est encore
mieux et ça tombe bien ils sont de plus
en plus nombreux à participer à paris
saclay la spring certains sont même un
fidèle au rendez-vous comme cariste à
cette société de capital-risque a
développé un lien particulier un lien
privilégié avec le cluster paris saclay
nous avons rencontré sa directrice
générale catherine bull elle revient sur
les secteurs prometteurs comme la santé
digital un fonds de 50 millions d'euros
lui et même maintenant révolue karysta
c'est une société de gestion de capital
risque ce qui a été créé vingt ans
maintenant j'en suis la directrice
générale et je m'occupe plus
particulièrement dans cette société de
la practice santé on a investi depuis 20
ans dans des sociétés innovantes à ces
jeunes
or les stages donc amorçage série a dans
tous les domaines de l'innovation
plus récemment on a investi dans une
société qui est basée dans le 78 donc
sur le plateau qui s'appelle michael my
personal life stop qui se dédie à
développer une plateforme
digital pour récupérer les données des
patients malades de cancer et faciliter
l'accès aux médecins lors des réunions
de concertation pluridisciplinaire à ces
données patients de manière intelligente
historiquement karysta et l investisseur
régional donc de la région ile de france
on s'appelait encore il ya à peine un an
capdecisif management et donc on a des
liens très particuliers avec le
territoire francilien et en particulier
avec le plateau de saclay donc on est
très content de participer tous les ans
à paris saclay spring et d'y trouver un
certain nombre de projets l'avantagent
de ceux de cet endroit c'est que c'est
des différents types de secteurs
d'activité à la fois de la santé la
biotech mais aussi des sciences de
l'ingénieur le digital et l'aditec nous
on est les investisseurs qui
investissons dans tous ces danses où ces
secteurs là où c'est un pourvoyeur de
dossiers de projets très intéressants
pour nous
notre agenda à présent vivent le
déconfinement vous allez pouvoir
profiter à fond de tous les événements
qui vous sont proposés l'université
paris saclay vous ouvre les portes du 2
au 4 juin pour son forum apprentissage
2021 c'est la première édition est
l'objectif
recrutez vos apprentis dans la meilleure
université de france vous le savez votre
avis est essentiel pour ne paie à paris
saclay la concertation sur la zac gare
de guyancourt saint-quentin quartier des
savoirs est lancé il y avait déjà les
balades urbaines qui était proposé
maintenant il ya des ateliers
thématiques pour changer sur tous les
sujets trois ateliers au programme
le premier c'est le 5 juin de 10h à 12h
en présentiel le thème habiter le
quartier des savoirs le 12 juin c'est
toujours de 10h à 12h en présentiel
le parc du quartier des savoirs et le
devenir de la halle piano et enfin le 19
juin toujours de 10h à 12h en présentiel
être usagers de la gare du grand paris
autre rendez vous pour les sportifs ne
ratez pas le tour paris saclay 2021
vététistes vous êtes attendus nombreux
pour cette nouvelle édition qui se
déroule le dimanche 6 juin au départ de
l'université paris saclay à bures sur
yvette
autre grand rendez vous festif mais moi
sportif
la fête de la création et des métiers
d'art retrouvait plus de 80 artisans
créateurs au domaine de saint jean de
beauregard
donc c'est du 11 au 13 juin il vous
invite à venir profiter des belles
journées ensoleillées mais surtout à
découvrir leur talent et leur savoir
faire
voilà c'est déjà la fin de cette
émission merci à vous de l'avoir suivi
je vous souhaite de très belles journées
ensoleillées un bon déconfinement prenez
soin de vous et restez prudent on se
retrouve très vite
et d'ici là restez informé sur notre
site pap.fr
[Musique]